euh comment va Nadia alors Nadia elle
est occupé l'appartement des deux
retraités qu'on avait reçu ici
elle est elle est elle est où là
actuellement elle est reloger ou pas
neurologer on a trouvé comme une grande
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui ne
souhaitait pas être aidé c'est quelqu'un
qui est autonome donc du coup elle a
retrouvé un logement d'accord c'est
propre au moyen et aujourd'hui on a déjà
va bien avec comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer
la machine à laver médiatique qu'il a
quand même un petit peu usé quelques
difficultés qui rencontrent mais elle
est en train de se reconstruire et j'ose
espérer que ça va être mieux pour elle
et le couple de retraités retrouvé son
sa maison de retraité en tout cas n'est
plus là-bas pour vous dire s'ils sont
là-bas ou pas je peux pas vous le dire
mais en tout cas Nadia effectivement
retrouver un logement d'accord alors
Laurent vous on rappelle votre histoire
vous avez acheté une maison avec votre
femme Élodie 140000 euros l'année
dernière dans l'Essonne vous avez eu du
mal à l'habiter car une famille de
squatteur occuper des lieux sur les
réseaux sociaux on a appris qu'ils
avaient acheté la maison à bas prix en
sachant que leur maison était squattées
c'est ça l'histoire c'est ce qu'on avait
c'était ça l'histoire exactement donc
voilà et aujourd'hui j'y habite tout va
bien les travaux
c'est dur mais on avance d'accord plus
de problème plus de problème ils sont
partis ils sont partis j'ai plus jamais
revu plus de nouvelles plus de nouvelles
d'accord très bien alors
aujourd'hui vous avez vu donc il y a des
squatteurs qui ont été
qui ont été donc délogés par des
gendarmes d'une maison à Villedieu à
Lavilledieu d'ailleurs c'était hier qui
Gilles vous vous trouvez que c'est pas
normal parce que ils vont durcir les
lois sur les squatteurs pour dire ce qui
va se passer maintenant alors la loi va
être durcie effectivement les squatteurs
pourront être passifs de 3 ans de prison
au lieu d'un et de 45000 € d'amende
contre 15000 donc ça c'est passé au
Sénat hier et donc normalement
l'Assemblée nationale devrait confirmer
on aura un durcissement de la loi mais
je reviens à votre question sur le fait
de déloger des squatteurs en plein hiver
alors
une fois je vais être hors-la-loi
pourquoi parce que on a le droit on a le
droit de virer des squatteurs ce ne sont
pas comme des locataires mauvais payeurs
on a le droit vous avez le droit de les
expulser mais les expulser alors que la
semaine prochaine on va avoir un froid
terrible en France notamment dans la
Creuse vous allez jeter deux personnes
de 20 ans à la rue je vous rappelle que
c'est un fléau vous allez accroître le
nombre de SDF
[Musique]
tu l'as dit dans ton énoncé tu t'es
cramé tout ça dans la maison pas du tout
dans la maison qu'il squatait j'étais
cramé tout seul mais ils peuvent aller
bosser mais enquêtes inhabité il voulait
travailler dans cette maison il voulait
créer un endroit collectif
[Musique]
et j'ai dit que je ne l'ai pas pour une
fois premièrement effectivement la loi
autorise à faire une différenciation
entre les mauvais payeurs parce qu'ils
ont un souci de vie et des squatteurs
qui viennent et là en l'occurrence c'est
en plus pas d'enfant c'est pas une
famille sont deux jeunes de 20 ans et
ensuite tu dis il voulait créer
effectivement un lieu notamment pour
vendre du pain des choses un peu
associatif et ben tu vas pas par
effraction pour faire ça tu vas sonner à
la porte de Monsieur le Maire et tu dis
à Monsieur le Maire écoutez j'ai un
projet de vie pour le village pour faire
pour réveiller le village comment est-ce
qu'on peut travailler main dans la main
et des nous on n'a pas forcément
beaucoup de moyens le village n'était
pas contre en plus et donc tu vas pas
faire par effraction
moi aussi je peux dire n'importe quoi
moi aussi
je vais faire une maison d'eau tu peux
aller pour accueillir des gens qui sont
en difficulté arrête de croire et toi
franchement arrête de croire au Père
Noël mon chéri excuse-moi
mettre ses roues si vous savez que vous
êtes d'accord avec Gilles
bien sûr moi j'aime beaucoup mais
au-delà de ça si vous voulez je suis
plutôt légaliste alors je suis légaliste
dans le sens où il y a une loi cette
fois la vocation s'appliquée
effectivement Gilles Verdun à raison ces
gens-là doivent être expulsés parce que
j'allais dire en tant que squatteur
pendant la tribunal c'est très ne
s'applique pas maintenant moi en
revanche ce que je dis c'est que cette
loi pour moi me pose problème ah
d'accord un pose problème pourquoi parce
que d'un côté vous pensez que l'équateur
il faut les laisser pendant la trêve
hivernale alors maintenant moi je pense
si vous voulez que soit tout le monde
est logé à la même enseigne soit tout le
monde est logé à m'enseigne auquel cas
il y a pas de différence
une maladie ou autre et qui pendant deux
trois mois peut-être aura des soucis
pour régler sa situation je l'entends
parfaitement les gens pour moi il y a un
fraction le mec qui rentre dans la
maison c'est quoi ça mais attendez on
pose une question si je peux répondre
moi ce que je veux dire c'est que
qu'est-ce qui différencie pour vous
quelqu'un qui rentre dans un logement
avec un bail qui reste en deux trois
quatre ensemble jamais de payer un euro
de loyer et finalement cette personne-là
ne peut pas être expulsée parce qu'elle
est protégée par la loi puisque la loi
pendant la période anale empêche le
préfet de le mettre en place je dis pas
deux trois alors attends je dis juste
jusqu'à la fin d'accord
c'est dans un cas on a autorisé la
personne à rentrer et dans notre cas
elle est rentrée toute seule c'est déjà
pas la même chose c'est inadmission
est de savoir à partir de combien de
mois non payé la personne devient
mauvais payeur à squatteur effectivement
parce que on peut se dire deux mois
trois mois et ensuite on paye mais
effectivement si ça dépasse 6 mois au
bout d'un moment à la fin de la pression
non mais d'abord il y a des assurances
aujourd'hui pour loyer impayés donc on
peut s'en sortir et tout ça c'est pas du
tout la même chose dans un cas on a
signé un bail avec quelqu'un on a
accepté après la personne a merdé bon
c'est c'est avoir il y a des assurances
il y a plein de choses dans l'autre cas
quelqu'un est rentré chez vous par
infraction et tout d'un coup il existe
des fractions et tout d'un coup les
décès qui était chez vous pardon maître
c'est pas du tout la même chose et déjà
tout à l'heure que vous êtes arrivés
c'est incroyable vous êtes arrivé en
disant aujourd'hui Nadia va bien elle
est partie elle a trouvé un appartement
elle a marché non je suis ravi vous êtes
arrivé à nous étions
elle avait fait le bien autour d'elle et
tout Nadia juste rendu un appartement
elle payait pas ses loyers et elle a
enfin fait ce qu'elle devait faire après
trois ou quatre ans on va pas en faire
un une héroïne non plus je pense que
vous êtes au sol pardon je pense que
vous êtes totalement hors sol quoi je
vous l'ai dit je vais vous l'expliquer
ça veut dire quoi je vais vous donner
l'explication vous êtes hors-sol
pourquoi vous êtes enceinte premièrement
parce que vous êtes en train de
m'expliquer qu'il y a des assurances
est-ce que vous savez quels sont les
conditions pour qu'un assureur assure
votre logement en cas de loyer impayés
vous êtes hors sol on gagne tous notre
vie ici aucune difficulté pour qu'on
soit assuré mais les gens qui sont à
l'extérieur c'est pas le cas il faut
gagner ça c'est vrai il faut il faut
gagner un minimum trois fois le montant
des loisirs ce que vous connaissez le
montant du loyer qui va assurer
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui travaille avec
1200 € par mois c'est pas possible donc
ce que vous êtes en train de dire ne
s'applique pas dans la vérité ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose je
pense que vous méconnaissez totalement
l'origine la très hivernale c'est la
même pierre que bien sûr d'accord 2023
je suis désolé de vous le dire l'abbé
Pierre en 203 ou pas en l'occurrence
c'est la même pire que c'est très bien
malade existe encore et pour moi et je
vais être clair avec vous les gens qui
sont squatteurs ou ceux qui ont un bail
qui ne payent pas on fera de la même
façon alors mais on s'en la
question mais la question est-ce qu'il
fallait les dehors les mais oui
c'est pas la question maître la question
c'est que aujourd'hui
car moi c'est ma résidence principale
donc ça aurait été moi à leur place là
c'est ça moi aussi j'ai froid
mais moi apparemment ça le dérange pas
moi
ça fait 8 ans qu'ils étaient dans cette
maison inoccupés
le 2 février on pouvait pas attendre le
23 mars la fin de la trêve hivernale
mais enfin vous délirez vous avez 8 ans
qu'ils auraient dû être parti et les
avocats adultes les avocats vivent de ça
parce que chaque année on sait qu'elle a
la loi et puis il y a l'application de
la loi alors la loi c'est ils peuvent
être virés mais comme c'est très long
l'application de la loi on arrive à
l'hiver ils peuvent pas durer le temps
de remettre la loi en ré-arrhée et ça
dure comme ça des années et puis il y a
des avocats qui viennent de l'argent
faut arrêter tout ça maintenant elle a
très la trêve hivernale on sait que ça
va durer 4-5 ans Sophie tu veux parler à
Gilles
ils étaient pas dans la baraque depuis 8
ans puisque ils sont pas arrivés à 12
ans les deux mecs
tu dis n'importe quoi
c'est pas parce que la maison elle était
inoccupée parce que les propriétaires et
décédé et son fils a décidé de récupérer
voilà bon il est occupait pas la maison
mais c'est pas une raison de rentrer
chez les gens et de s'y installer
Gilles le pauvre c'est qui il veut faire
plaisir à tout le monde mais à un moment
tu peux pas tu peux pas en fait tu peux
pas décider à un moment décider c'est
froisser quelques personnes à un moment
toi tu veux faire plaisir à tout le
monde en fait à l'arrivée tu vas faire
plaisir à personne ça s'entend ton
argument s'il s'agit d'une famille avec
des enfants qui fait froid etc là c'est
deux ce sont deux jeunes excuse-moi mais
deux jeunes mes 20 ans tu peux tu peux
tu peux tu peux trouver tu vas frapper
aux portes tu vas aux associations tu
travailles quoi tu bosses tu vois tu
tuer
je sais plus quoi lui dire à Gilles
ces gens-là concrètement vous les mettez
où est-ce que c'est le problème
c'est pas le squat qui doit rester le
problème des propriétés chez vous je
suis en train de parler en général
ce que je vous dis c'est que ces gens-là
vous savez qu'il y a 300000 personnes
qui sont dans la rue mais il y a 58
enfants ces gens-là lorsqu'ils partent
de chez eux finalement ils partent c'est
pas le même prix
il y a des logements sociaux s'il y a
des logements sociaux on en fait quoi
des logements sociaux il y a pas de
place
en France
c'est pas la question du propriétaire
je comprends tout à fait mais on est
tous et bien sûr on a envie que ça ça
qu'il y ait personne dans la rue c'est
vraiment parce que tout le monde
personne vous dira j'ai envie de voir
les gens dans la rue et ce n'est pas une
raison pour aller squatter une maison
qui n'est pas la nôtre et et c'est lui
non mais je comprends pas après tout ce
qu'on a entendu comment on peut encore
défendre les squatteurs ça c'est
toujours les mêmes arguments on veut
criminaliser les plus précaires mais les
propriétaires on en fait quoi les
propriétés l'immense majorité des
propriétaires ce ne sont pas des gens
fortunés c'est des gens qui parfois sont
aussi dans le besoin c'est-à-dire que
eux les laisse dehors et tout le monde
en a rien à et les squators vous
voulez les sauver vous vous en foutez
que lui soit dehors en revanche elle est
très bien mal d'accord le cas de Laurent
est un cas différent cette chanson
le coupe de retraité c'était pareil
d'abord premièrement moi je suis pas la
nuit pour défendre des squatteur ou pour
les incitations
bien d'accord lorsqu'on a travaillé tout
sa vie lorsqu'on a mis l'argent de côté
avec les difficultés des retraites qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui à l'évidence
d'accord quelqu'un qui a capitalisé qui
va avoir son loyer pour pouvoir vivre il
a le droit de la voir il y a aucune
difficulté mais aujourd'hui il y a une
réalité qu'on ne peut pas nier ces
gens-là on fait quoi voilà la réalité
dans ces cas-là attendez excusez-moi
vous m'invitez quand même pour parler
d'une loi qui a été passée quand même
par le pouvoir politique aujourd'hui
clairement la réalité on est là on fait
d’être passé mais on leur propose quoi
aux gens aujourd'hui
mais non mais non c'est soit la prison
sur la rue
sinon il va pas travailler
il y a beaucoup de gens qui travaillent
pas qui travaillent ensemble
c'est pas le travail ou la rue mais vous
vous confondez la prison à la rue c'est
vous confondez le travail des pouvoirs
publics avec le squat qui est pas là
pour réguler la crise du logement en
France et la loi qui vient de passer oui
on remet un peu d'égalité entre les
peines qui étaient attribuées aux
propriétaires qui viraient comme comme
Monsieur les squatteurs et les
squatteurs qui sont le problème de base
mais le problème en fait c'était pas la
loi et c'était pas la punition le
problème c'est que le pré les préfets
n'agissent pas alors on va pas cette
fois-ci regretter qu'un préfet est agi
peut vivre deux personnes de 20 ans qui
peuvent travailler gagner leur vie et
avoir un logement de façon normale comme
nous tous alors que d'habitude on se
plaint toute la journée que les préfets
n'appliquent pas les lois
c'est bizarre de manquer d'humanité à ce
point-là moi je vais vous poser une
simple question vous préférez que ces
deux personnes de 20 ans ces deux jeunes
hommes soit à la rue la semaine
prochaine et qui meurt de froid
[Applaudissements]
ou alors qu'on les laisse deux mois de
plus dans une maison inoccupée vous
voulez que ces deux personnes chez toi
bah voilà eh c'est deux personnes chez
elle nous écoute qu'elle aille chez
Gilles Verdez enfin tout n'est pas là en
ce moment-là
tu serais pas dans une caravane comme
Monsieur hein t'irait prendre un autre
appartement tu as les moyens donc déjà
c'est une autre question moi ce qui me
rend fou quand j'avais face à Baba
l'autre jour il y avait une vieille dame
qui m'a touché qui disait j'ai travaillé
40 ou 42 ans je gagne 1200 balles et il
y a des gens qui n'ont jamais rien foutu
qu'il gagne 960 donc c'est 240 euros
l'écart entre les gens qui foutent rien
et les gens qui travaillent et bien dans
ce pays c'est ça qui m'agace aussi il y
a des propriétaires qui ont travaillé
qu'il faut protéger et il faut arrêter
systématiquement pour se mettre du côté
de la bien-pensance de vouloir défendre
ceux qui ne travaillent pas ceux qui
squattent ceux qui rentrent par
effraction bah si c'est ça c'est ça le
problème ce monsieur n'a pas de
appartement
[Applaudissements]
il faut différencier entre quelqu'un qui
rentre par effraction qui se mord la loi
et une famille qui a des difficultés
pour payer son loyer et pour répondre à
Jésus tu fais c'est vrai tu es humain
tue deux personnes qu'on va
dehors qu'on vingt ans alors vous
travaillez c'est pas que le problème
c'est dur de ce jeu aussi quand tu
travailles tu vas deux personnes
dehors mais alors il est où ton côté
humaniste quand tu passes le matin sur
les grands boulevards parisiens et que
tu vois des gens dormir dans la rue par
terre ça te dérange pas ça te dérange
pour les deux personnes qui sont
rentrées par effraction moi ça me
dérange plus de voir des gens qui disent
de rien qui rentre pas chez les gens par
effraction qui crèvent de faim dehors
dans la rue tranquillement sans qu'on
s'occupe d'eux que les deux qui sont
rentrés en cassant des portes moi il me
dérange pas les deux qui sont en cassant
des portes il me dérange pas on rentre
pas en cassant des portes
ben oui
Gilles défends toujours les délinquants
ma chérie
franchement merci de me faire parler
après tout le monde où tout a été dit
donc j'apprécie mais qu'est-ce que tu
penses de ce que il a raison voilà
position de Gilles non d'habitude il est
dans la démagogie absolue il veut se
faire bien voir mais ce que tu vois
c'était inhabité moi si j'ai une baraque
et ben j'ai droit de le laisser inhabité
c'est ma maison voilà c'est mon droit et
chez moi et tu rentres pas chez moi
parfois le laisse il habite voilà la
nationalité
le seul bémol que je mets effectivement
c'est que si les gens sont de bonne foi
et qu'ils ont un vrai problème les gens
voilà on trouverait une solution mais
dans ce cas là on ne rentre pas chez les
gens pas en esparaitraction voilà
excuse-moi et Monsieur l'avocat
j'attends qu'il veut dire quand même
parce que vous êtes devenu plusieurs
fois et votre jeu quand même sympa
quand on vous entend parler vous trouvez
quand même le moyen d'essayer de tirer
la procédure le plus longtemps possible
bien sûr mais moi la vérité vous allez
quoi vous allez le reprocher de faire
bien
envie non mais c'est juste pas à cause
de vous grâce à vous donc il arrive à
tirer quand même à tirer les choses un
peu trop loin mec qui fait bien son
travail
je comprends pas la loi elle s'applique
aussi au squatteur non c'est la même loi
non
justement et après j'en aurai terminé
vous m'avez invité aujourd'hui pour
parler de cette loi moi je vais vous
dire une chose cette fois pour moi c'est
de la poudre de perlimpinpin ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que concrètement
avant on avait un an de prison c'est pas
ça trois ans de prison est-ce que
quelqu'un connaît ici n'est pas des
prisons français 150 % de surpopulation
ça ne sert à rien il y a des il y a des
criminels dans l'extérieur des
pédophiles qui sont dehors et on va
aller mettre en prison ces gens-là sont
pas très près
laissez-le finir deuxièmement on est
passé de 15000 euros à 45000 € d'amende
mais ces gens-là n'ont pas 1 € devant
eux qui va payer maintenant en
l'occurrence c'est de la démagogie pure
c'est une loi qui est démagogique et qui
pour moi ne change absolument rien qui
était plus
donc vous dites que les lois de servent
à rien si les gens sont un solvables
finalement c'est pas la peine de faire
des lois ça sert à rien parce que oui
sur les prisons c'est faux hier on a vu
un mec qui a acheté son chat par la
fenêtre il est prévu 8 ans de près OUI
ou NON
ferme alors arrêtez de dire aux gens en
fait les prisons sont pleines et vous
êtes à solvable alors faites
sérieusement on s'en bat les couilles
pas question n'est pas la question n'est
pas de dire allez en prison la question
n'est pas de dire on vous sort du squat
on vous met en prison la question c'est
d'envoyer le message de dire on ne peut
plus rentrer chez les gens impunément si
vous rentrez chez les gens impunément il
n'y a plus ce côté il y aura une trêve
jusqu'au mois de mars Au mois de mars
vous pouvez manger des cacahuètes ça
veut dire que vous pouvez vous faire
virer je joue au lendemain on vous on
vous parle pas d'aller en prison on ne
veut mettre personne en prison on dit
juste que quand tu rentres chez
quelqu'un en cassant une porte et en te
couvrant d'une association moi je vais
aller chez Cyril et je veux dire je
monte une association pour les pingouins
en danger
on va faire Delphine et j'aimerais qu'on
termine parce que j'aimerais qu'on soit
tous scénariste ce week-end on terminera
par Gilbert et laissera le mot de la fin
je pense qu'il faut arrêter de prioriser
de prioriser en fait les gens qui font
chier le monde je pense que concrètement
il faut ouvrir des nouvelles prises mais
ça c'est autre chose et je pense que un
squatteur a délibérément une ambi active
de nuire de voler ce qu'il n'y
appartient pas donc en fait au bout d'un
moment arrêtez de les excuser donc je
sais que vous faites votre boulot mais
arrêtez de les excuser et j'aimerais
encore vous dire il y a des gens qui
travaillent
totalement
job il y a des gens qui ont deux jeux
gratuitement d'une on peut cumuler les
jobs et de deux même si on travaille pas
il y a quand même le RSA et le RSA c'est
aussi fait avec nous impôts donc en fait
ça c'est l'État qui doit gérer ça mais
c'est pas les particul
s'il vous plait j'aimerais avoir la
Bible Lucas
Lucas qui a 29 ans en question
[Applaudissements]
on va laisser le mot de la fin à Gilles
Verdez le
[Applaudissements]
c'est toujours bon il nous énerve on est
énervé ce weekend c'est sympa je vais
vous parler avec mon cœur oh merde
je préfère j'espère que ton cœur et
dis-moi de conneries que ta tête
je préfère un squatteur dans une maison
inhabitée jusqu'à fin mars plutôt qu'un
squatteur en danger de mort dans le
froid la semaine prochaine
j'aimerais bien savoir quel squatteur
est en prison
ok merci